Amigos, las Islas Malvinas son uno de los
territorios más inhóspitos, remotos y aislados
del planeta.
Situadas a unos 400km de la Patagonia argentina,
Las Malvinas están formadas por más de 700
islas que tienen una superficie de aproximadamente
12 mil kilómetros cuadrados, algo más que
Puerto Rico, Chipre o el Líbano.
Sin embargo, a pesar de ello, ¿Sabéis qué
población tienen estas islas? Pues… apenas
3.400 personas.
Es decir, en este archipiélago la densidad
de población viene a ser de 1 habitante por
cada 4 kilómetros cuadrados.
Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, esto hace
que las Malvinas formen, junto a Groenlandia
y el archipiélago ártico de Svalbard, el
podium de los territorios autónomos más
deshabitados del planeta.
[Dicho de otro modo, hablamos de unas islas
donde es mucho más fácil encontrarse con
pingüinos que con personas.]
Para que os hagáis una idea, tan solo un
estadio de fútbol como el Santiago Bernabéu
tiene un aforo que es 23, 23 veces más grande
que toda la población de Las Malvinas.
Pero, cuidado, no solo es que estén casi
deshabitadas. Es que además, como ya sabéis
mantienen una enorme disputa con Argentina,
que las reclama como territorio propio.
Y cómo Argentina es el país más cercano,
eso hace que en la práctica estas islas estén
muy pero que muy aisladas.
Y es aquí donde nos surgen unas cuantas preguntas,
¿De qué diantres viven Las Malvinas?
¿Por qué son tan polémicas?
¿Puede un territorio tan pequeño sobrevivir?¿Ser
sostenible?
Amigos, ¿Sabríais contestar a estas preguntas?
¿Y qué pasa si os digo que Las Malvinas
pueden convertirse en uno de los territorios
más ricos del mundo? No me creéis, atentos.
(¿DE QUÉ VIVEN LAS MALVINAS?)
Amigos, os hago una pregunta: ¿sabríais
decirme cuál es el territorio autónomo más
rico de América Latina?
Puede que muchos estés pensando en Puerto
Rico, Chile o Panamá, ¿Verdad?
Pues no, nada de eso. Con un producto interior
bruto de más de 60 mil dólares per cápita,
el territorio más rico de Latinoamérica
son Las Malvinas.
Hablamos de casi 5 veces el PIB per cápita
de Argentina.
[Sí, ya sé que Las Malvinas no son un país,
pero tienen sus propias instituciones de gobierno
y muchísimas competencias. En la práctica
son casi como un país]
Y su economía va viento en popa y a toda
vela.
(A pesar de estar aisladas y prácticamente
deshabitadas, durante la última década la
economía local ha promediado un crecimiento
económico de más del 5% anual en términos
reales.
Y no solo eso, a diferencia del resto de gobiernos
latinoamericanos - bueno y de casi todos los
gobiernos del mundo - las autoridades locales
no sólo no tienen deudas sino que acumulan
unas reservas, algo así como un fondo soberano,
de más de 250 millones de dólares.)
Ojo, porque 250 millones de dólares nos puede
parecer poco dinero, pero si tenemos en cuenta
su escasa población, hablamos de que los
ahorros de gobierno superan los 75.000 dólares
por cada habitante de las islas.
Pero… vale, vale todo esto está muy bien,
pero regresemos a la pregunta con la que empezamos,
¿de qué diantres viven estas islas?
Puede que aquí muchos tengáis la tentación
de pensar así cómo… vamos a ver, Enrique,
¿Qué nos estás contando?
Las Malvinas son un territorio de Reino Unido…
seguro, seguro que están subvencionadas hasta
las trancas y que el sector público es la
actividad más importante, ¿verdad?
Pues, amigos, lo cierto es que no, nada de
eso.
(“No tenemos ninguna duda acerca de nuestra
soberanía, que ha sido continua desde 1833”.
Margaret Thatcher.)
Las Malvinas son un territorio autosuficiente…
Reino Unido tan solo se hace cargo de los
costes de defensa… nada más.
[Y esos costes ni son tan grandes ni serían
necesarios si no fuera por el conflicto político
existente.]
Veréis, lo cierto amigos, es que Las Malvinas
eran unas islas relativamente pobres que probablemente
estaban condenadas a despoblarse, pero en
1987 todo cambio.
Los habitantes de la isla se dieron cuenta
de que tenían que prosperar y aprendieron
a hacer negocios. Y amigos, en eso de hacer
negocios los británicos son todos unos campeones.
(Su forma de vida es británica; Su lealtad
es a la corona. Son pocos en número, pero
tienen el derecho de vivir en paz, de elegir
su propia forma de vida y de determinar su
propia lealtad. […] Es el deseo del pueblo
británico y el deber del gobierno de Su Majestad
hacer todo lo posible para defender ese derecho.
Esa será nuestra esperanza y nuestro esfuerzo.
Margaret Thatcher.)
El caso es que en 1987, el gobierno de Las
Malvinas comenzó a vender licencias a empresas
pesqueras extranjeras para que operaran dentro
de su zonas de pesca, dé su territorio marítimo.
Es decir, comenzaron a tratar a sus aguas
como si de cualquier otro recurso se tratará.
Gracias a esta medida el gobierno recauda
un montón de dinero cada año. [Y también
se preocupa mucho de la sostenibilidad de
la pesca… para que no se termine la fuente
de ingresos.]
Pero aquí no termina todo ni muchísimo menos.
Desde esa época el gobierno de Las Malvinas
ha tenido 3 cosas muy pero que muy claras:
Primero, que hay que alentar la creación
de empresas. Los habitantes de Las Malvinas
- que se conocen todos - tienen que vivir
de lo que produzca su trabajo, no de los impuestos
y el gasto público.
Segundo, para que esto sea posible los impuestos
tienen que ser moderados. Y de hecho lo son.
Fijaos, en Las Malvinas no existe el impuesto
a las compras, los impuestos especiales son
reducidos - la gasolina es más barata que
en el Reino Unido - y una persona que digamos
gane 2.500 dólares al mes, pagará en impuestos
un total de 140 dólares mensuales, es decir,
apenas un 5,6%
Y tercero el gobierno local no solo no tiene
que endeudarse, sino que tiene que ahorrar.
[¿Deuda? No queremos deudas]
Como podéis ver en este gráfico los superávits
son casi una obligación.
(De esta forma, los habitantes de Las Malvinas
no solo no tienen que pagar intereses de la
deuda pública sino que cada año obtienen
un montón de beneficios por los ahorros del
fondo soberano y además, cuando lo necesitan,
tienen capacidad para invertir:
que es lo que ahora están haciendo lanzándose
a construir un nuevo puerto, una ampliación
del aeropuerto, etcétera, etcétera.)
Pues bien, gracias a todo esto, en Las Malvinas
no hay paro y el 90% de las personas en edad
de trabajar tienen un empleo.
En los últimos años sectores como el turismo
o el de las piscifactorías se han disparado.
Las cosas van tan bien que los planes del
gobierno pasan porque en los próximos años
la población de la islas prácticamente se
duplique con la llegada de trabajadores extranjeros.
[La parte mala, es que cómo están tan aislados
y son tan pocos pues aquí Amazon no llega,
el internet es muy lento y desde luego salvo
que os guste la naturaleza, pasarlo bien puede
llegar a ser una tarea complicada.]
Pero, amigos, esta no es nada con lo que puede
estar por venir. Atentos.
(¿CAMINO A LA RIQUEZA?)
Creo que no hay dudas de que los habitantes
de Las Malvinas han sabido hacer las cosas
bien.
[Lo que nos dice que incluso en un territorio
tan pequeño y tan aislado se puede tener
éxito cuando las cosas se hacen con cabeza.
Y no es difícil porque no hace falta inventar
nada. Con hacer todo lo contrario a esto es
más que suficiente]
"La expropiación de la empresa Cidetour"
Pero, amigos, a pesar de que las cosas ya
están tan bien por estos lares, la suerte
de los habitantes de las Malvinas está a
punto de dar un nuevo salto a la estratosfera.
Fijaos.
(En 1993 el centro geológico británico localizó
petróleo bajo las aguas que rodean Las Malvinas.
Petróleo explotable.
Tras años de intensos trabajos… ahora el
resultado puede empezar a dar sus frutos.
Dos pequeñas petroleras británicas, la Rockhopper
Exploration y la Premier Oil, están a punto
de empezar a construir la infraestructura
que permitirá que en apenas 3 años la producción
petrolera de Las Malvinas supere los 80.000
barriles diarios. Tan solo necesitan que el
precio del petróleo se mantenga por encima
de los 45$ por barril para que el negocio
sea rentable.)
Sí, vale, 80.000 barriles puede parecer poco…
pero no olvides que estamos hablando de Las
Malvinas.
80.000 barriles al precio actual de unos 60$
por barril suponen un ingreso anual de
1.800 millones de dólares.
El 9% de todo estos ingresos y el 26% de los
beneficios finales que obtengan las petroleras
irán a manos del gobierno local. Hablamos
de una cifra que probablemente superará los
200 millones de dólares.
Es decir, tan solo en ingresos públicos cerca
de 60.000 dólares adicionales por habitante
y año.
[Y por supuesto luego estarían los empleos,
los salarios y los impuestos que toda esta
nueva industria va a generar.]
(Y, ojo, tan solo estamos hablando del comienzo,
porque en estos momento hay más zonas que
están siendo exploradas. Si las cosas marchan
bien en 10 años la producción diaria de
Las Malvinas podría superar ampliamente los
100.000 barriles cada día..
En total se calcula que las reservas explotables
de petróleo de este archipiélago podrían
superar los 1.000 millones de barriles.)
Amigos, si cumplen los plazos, en apenas unos
años Las Malvinas podrían convertirse en
uno de los lugares más ricos de todo el planeta.
(“Puedo asegurar que una cosa nunca cambiará:
nuestro compromiso absoluto con el pueblo
y la soberanía de las Islas Falkland”.
Theresa May.)
Hoy Las Malvinas nos pueden parecer un lugar
inhóspito, pero… con trabajo, buenos salarios,
impuestos bajos, mejores comunicaciones, un
estado de derecho sólido, poca corrupción,
muchas libertades civiles y mucha seguridad,
a lo mejor cambia nuestra impresión sobre
la vida en estas islas.
Sobre todo si, desgraciadamente, la comparamos
con la vida en otros países del continente.
Amigos, esta es la realidad a la que se enfrentan
Las Malvinas.
Desde luego más allá de la soberanía, si
se cumplen las previsiones, estas islas podrían
ser toda un negocio para las regiones del
sur de Argentina.
Tal vez haya llegado la hora de aparcar viejas
dispuestas y buscar un beneficio para todos,
¿No os parece?
(“Cuando me reuní con el Presidente Macri
a principios de este mes, convirtiéndome
en el primer Primer Ministro británico en
visitar Buenos Aires, fue un placer concentrarme
no solo en lo que nos separa, sino sobre todo
en lo que podemos lograr juntos”. Theresa
May.)
Si os ha resultado interesante el vídeo darle
a like y no olvideis suscribiros a VisualPolitik,
pensadlo un momento ¿En que otro canal podríais
encontrar vídeos sobre la economía de un
lugar que apenas tiene 3.400 habitantes?
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.